[Music]
on this Saturday night the new
coronavirus surpasses SARS more
infections and more deaths everyone who
wants to come back home can come back
home as more Canadians wait to get out
of China a soldier in Thailand goes on a
shooting spree the motive behind the
deadly rampage stiff competition what
Canada faces in the fight for a UN
Security Council seat and finding the
right fit we always have kind of done
unique souls for unique souls to
Canadians team up to make the perfect
pair
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us the new corona virus outbreak has
passed a grim milestone tonight after a
brief respite the number of new cases
has risen again at least 36 thousand
people are infected including three more
on the quarantined Diamond Princess
cruise ship Chinese authorities say 81
more people have died in China bringing
the death toll to at least 800 that
surpasses the 774 deaths recorded
globally during the 2002 2003 SARS
outbreak one of the most recent deaths
in Wuhan a US citizen this 60 year old
is believed to be the first American to
die from the new corona virus meanwhile
more than 200 Canadians are under
quarantine
tonight at CFB Trenton after being
airlifted out of China dozens more
remain in the epicenter of the outbreak
waiting for government help to get home
Michael Couture explains when they might
return to Canada and what they can
expect when they get here I am prepared
for the worst
but I'm hoping for the best these are
tense times for Amelia Penn her husband
caught the corona virus while in Wuhan
China with their two-year-old daughter
the toddler missed the first Canadian
evacuation flight because she had a
fever she's better now and Pan is hoping
the government will help get her home
hopefully they can find somebody to act
as a temporary custodian for my daughter
Serena it's unclear if the federal
government will even consider that pan
would go get her daughter herself but no
commercial flights are allowed into
Wuhan meanwhile the 213 Canadians and
those with permanent resident status in
quarantine at CFB Trenton are getting
used to their new surroundings and
routines which does include a bit of
time outside the movements are still
restricted but for Miriam LaHood it's
better than being in China but here I
know that in 40 days I'm gonna be out
Emily
Lelouch and the others are expected to
get some company next week that's when
another 150 Canadian citizens and people
with permanent resident status were
still in Wuhan China could be airlifted
back home
on a second government Charter the time
between the last flight and the next one
well era was really to be in touch with
everyone making sure that when when our
second Canadian plane leaves you on that
everyone wants to come back home can
come back the Canadian officials are
also keeping an eye on three cruise
ships in Asia which have been halted to
placed in quarantine according to the
different cruise lines that are more
than 550 Canadians on those vessels and
seven have tested positive for the
coronavirus those people have been
removed and are now in hospital American
Matthew Smith is on the diamond princess
and he says the crew has been great but
they've been told the ship's clinic is
very busy and they have to monitor
themselves we were given the
thermometers and the captain asked us to
self test several times a day and if the
temperature was thirty seven point five
centigrade or above to report to the
Medical Center one of the three ships
isn't being allowed to dock in Japan
even though there are no confirmed cases
of the virus on board our foreign
affairs minister spoke to the CEO of
that cruise line and was told that
everything is being done to ensure the
health and safety of Canadians onboard
the ship
Robin Michael Couture in Ottawa thanks
Mike
to breaking news in Thailand police now
say an officer has been killed in a raid
at a shopping mall to stop a soldier on
a shooting rampage at least 21 people
have been killed and dozens more injured
in the attack it began this afternoon in
a city about 250 kilometers northeast of
Bangkok the shooter began his rampage at
a military base before moving on to a
popular mall that's where the suspect
has been holed up for hours tonight
explosions and shots can still be heard
as police searched the mall for the
shooter
Reggie Cecchini reports a frantic scene
at a shopping mall in Thailand
as a suspect stormed the building and
began shooting at large and while many
managed to escape with the aid of
authorities an unknown number were
trapped inside we are trying to bring
out whoever we can first and we will
gradually save the others who are still
stuck inside says the country's Public
Health Minister the suspect believed to
be a 32 year old member of the army was
reportedly angry over a land dispute the
incident started on a military base
where he allegedly attacked and killed a
commanding officer and at least two
others he's then alleged to have stolen
a vehicle driving roughly 11 kilometers
north to the terminal 21 shopping center
where he gunned down a number of
civilians outside before entering the
suspect can be seen roaming the
corridors armed with a large rifle I was
wondering if he was going to come near
me because the noise felt like it was so
close while we were hiding this shopper
says amid the confusion and chaos a
desperate attempt to get in touch with
loved ones this man talking to his
girlfriend tells her he heard the
gunshots and says I told her to calm
down that authorities are coming that's
all I can do this is the second time
this year a mall in Thailand has come
under fire in January three people died
during an armed robbery in the city of
La pari including a two-year-old boy and
while gun ownership is legal in the
country mass shootings outside of
localized gang violence are rare
authorities say the suspect in
Saturday's shooting used weapons stolen
from a military base his social media
sites have been pulled down but not
before he allegedly broadcast himself on
Facebook saying I am tired and my
fingers hurt and as hospitals continue
to treat victims of this shooting
incident the man who at one time was
tasked with serving and protecting his
country has become Thailand's most
wanted person regi Cecchini Global News
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau is in
Ethiopia where he's campaigning to win
support from African nations for
Canada's bid to win a Security Council
seat our chief political correspondent
David akin is traveling with the Prime
Minister and reports that Canada isn't
the only country campaigning in Africa
right now
the 55 members of the African Union hold
a summit twice a year and at this one
for the very first time a Canadian Prime
Minister addressed the gathering today
as part of Canada's increased support to
the African Union I'm pleased to
announce that we will provide 10 million
dollars to help build the capacity of
the African Union Commission to advance
gender equality the applause with that
promise of 10 million dollars was the
start of Justin Trudeau's day he
finished at a panel discussion on the
so-called blue economy was her economic
activities based on ocean and lake
resources reminding his African host
that two years ago Canada promised to
spend 100 million dollars to help rid o
sh ins of plastics and other wastes
that's a theme important to African
Union voters here Canada is ready to be
your partner on a blue economy strategy
for joint action for people right across
Africa those are the kind of financial
commitments that are a key part of the
campaign that Canada is mounting to win
a seat at the United Nations Security
Council a seat that would give Canadian
diplomats daily access to senior
officials from the world's most powerful
countries it's even more important right
now when we're having trouble
negotiating with the Chinese
Adam chap Nick is the author of a new
history of Canada at the Security
Council we'll be sitting beside them at
the Security Council day in day out for
two years if we have a seat on the
council on sometimes that's how
diplomacy gets done but Canada is facing
stiff competition from Ireland and
Norway for the two spots that will come
open in June indeed ten minutes after
Trudeau wrapped up a meeting with
Ethiopia's president Saleh worked xot
day Norway's Prime Minister Erna Solberg
pulled up at the presidential palace for
her meeting with President zou day
Norway argues it has been a constant
partner for Africa and spends five times
more on foreign aid relatively speaking
than Canada does our difficulty now is a
bit as we and Canada have a same
approach but maybe we have been a most
steady partnership for the
multilateralism for a long time now
that's a bit of a dig at a line that
Trudeau and his ministers once used to
boast about their own foreign policy and
criticize the harper conserved
remember Canada is back well Norway and
Ireland are reminding UN voters that
they never left Robin
David Aken in Ethiopia the premiers of
New Brunswick Quebec Ontario
Saskatchewan and Alberta are in
Washington they're pursuing trade
agreements with individual states in
hopes of getting around the Trump
administration stringent by American
policies while their Alberta premier
Jason Kenney took the opportunity to
criticize Democratic opponents of the
Keystone XL pipeline project during a
joint press conference at the Canadian
embassy Kenney said some Democratic
presidential hopefuls who promised to
stop construction of the pipeline
expansion are threatening Canada's
economic interests why are they prepared
to do great economic damage to their
closest friend and Ally the most
progressive and liberal source of energy
on earth when they don't threaten to ban
OPEC imports in the United States if the
United States is not a if Americans are
not able to depend more on Canadian
energy in the future guess what they'll
have to depend more on OPEC dictatorship
oil Kenny says Canada has helped reduce
global greenhouse gas emissions by
massively expanding liquefied natural
gas development and exports RCMP
officers have made more arrests at an
encampment in northern BC where
indigenous groups want to block the
construction of a pipeline that would
transport liquefied natural gas from
Alberta to the BC coast Global Sarah
MacDonald is following the story in
northern BC Sarah Robyn this area in
northern BC used to be open to members
of the public that is until Friday when
RCMP expanded its controversial
so-called exclusion zone keeping nearly
everybody safe for select individuals
and a few members of the media
new arrests were conducted on Saturday
with pipeline opponents refusing to
vacate now considered to be in defiance
of that injunction RCMP have been tasked
with enforcing as a second criminal
investigation is launched for mischief
over allegations that crucial
infrastructure has been tampered with
the hereditary Chiefs of what so at a
nation this large swath of unceded
territory outside Houston BC say they
have ultimate jurisdiction over this
land and they don't consent to the 6.6
billion dollar natural gas pipeline
slated to run through it even though the
energy giant behind it has all the
proper permits to put shovels in the
ground and the support of the provincial
and federal governments and elected
First Nations councils in northern BC
well certainly it's not the outcome we
had hoped for or have been working
toward over the past number of months
it's illegal what they're doing everyone
that they arrested and removed from our
territory
were never charged it's just harassment
and they were not impeding any access at
all they were in the homes it will
likely take days for RCMP to access the
main encampment housing more people
staunchly opposed to the pipeline at
this point meaning robbing those most
recent arrests seen here today are
almost certainly not going to be the
last Sara MacDonald near Houston BC
would you like to see them move these
guys out of here so you can get on with
your jobs I want to move it I can
deliver they're trying to go home
I don't want stuck here in Vancouver a
long line of truckers stalled on highway
are on a highway off-ramp as protestors
who claim to be supporting the
indigenous pipeline opponents blocked
access to the Port of Vancouver for a
third straight day the action caused
heavy traffic backups and the Port of
Vancouver says some operations were
immediately impacted an anger of the
arrests NBC is on display at
demonstrations in Ontario dozens of
protesters crowded onto a Toronto GO
Transit line saying they're putting
their bodies on the line for the web
sweatin people a separate blockade near
Belleville Ontario has forced Via Rail
to cancel trains for a second day on
routes operating between Toronto and
Montreal and between Toronto and Ottawa
Montreal is digging out after a winter
wallop brought 40 centimeters of snow in
a day 3000 city employees hit the
streets in nearly as many snow clearing
vehicles today it's the fifth major
operation of the season
the snowstorm closed all city schools
canceled and delayed dozens of flights
and caused commuter chaos yesterday
residents across the mayor of times are
dealing with the aftermath of that same
system snow freezing rain and strong
winds swept across the region yesterday
thousands of people are still without
power in many areas down under they're
drenched coming up from fire to floods
in Australia
fire ravaged Australia is dealing with a
new problem rain and lots of it New
South Wales was dredged today by the
heaviest rainfall in almost 20 years the
severe weather flooded roads submerging
vehicles there are still more than 35
active fires in the region about half
are contained the downpours are expected
to last until next week which may dampen
the fires a preliminary investigation is
ruling out engine failure in the
helicopter crash that killed Kobe Bryant
the US National Transportation Safety
Board says there are no signs the rotors
or engines failed before the crash
killing all nine people on board the
report includes witness photographs that
show the helicopter disappearing into
low cloud cover investigators say the
chopper nearly cleared the blinding
clouds when it suddenly plummeted into a
California hillside the left bank which
is increasing and the descent rate may
very well be indicators of spatial
disorientation that's certainly what the
investigators are going to look at no
cause has been determined a final report
isn't expected for about a year a public
memorial to remember the NBA legend and
his daughter Gianna will take place at
Staples Center on February 24th the date
is symbolic because it commemorates both
father and daughter's basketball jersey
numbers in Ireland voters are casting
their ballots in an election dominated
by anger over health care housing crisis
and homelessness the current leader
known as the T shock Leo broad car is
fighting for a third consecutive term
for his center-right party finna gale an
opposition party Fionna fall have
dominated Irish politics since
independence the calls for change have
seen the third partition feign top
opinion polls for the first time that
party doesn't have enough candidates to
win a majority and the other two say
they won't form a coalition wish in vain
over its path links to the IRA these
patient pumps are part of an election
tradition in Ireland voters are sharing
its pictures of their dogs outside
polling stations
[Music]
from stressing out about retirement
you're not alone a recent survey by cibc
found that over three-quarters of
Canadians aged 35 to 54 fear they won't
have enough money to retire when they
want but that mental block may stall you
from saving in this week's money one two
three online reporter Eric aleni shares
ways to turn procrastination into
motivation retirement is a very big goal
that is also very far off in the future
when you're young research shows the
human brain isn't very good at dealing
with that it's so easy to keep putting
it off and so hard to stay on track but
here are two ways to help your brain
along if you can get motivated to start
saving take a look at the numbers
postponing saving for retirement for
even a few years can make a big
difference let's say you start saving
five hundred dollars a month at age
thirty with four percent average annual
returns on your investments by age 65
you'd have just about four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars but if you
started saving only five years later at
35 your nest egg at 65 would be three
hundred and forty three thousand dollars
more than a hundred thousand dollars
less that's because the earlier you
start saving and investing that longer
your money has to grow but getting
started is just one of the problems
the other challenge is to keep going one
strategy to stay motivated is to give
yourself intermediate shorter term
retirement goals for example how much do
you want to have saved up by 30 and by
35 some say by age 30 you should have
the equivalent of 50% of your salary set
aside for retirement and by 35 the
equivalent of a hundred percent of your
salary
the advantage of setting short-term
intermediate targets when it comes to
saving for retirement is it gives you a
much more tangible and smaller number to
work with when it comes to setting your
savings targets for retirement it's
important to remember where you're
starting from if you spend a lot of time
in school pursuing a graduate with a
professional degree you might have more
debt and all
I've spent more time out of the
workforce so don't beat yourself up if
you feel behind it's really just
important that you start now and say
something don't get discouraged if those
targets seem high it's absolutely
possible to catch up but while it's
never too late to start saving for
retirement it's also never too early
that's your money 1 2 3 4 this week I'm
Erica aleni kind-hearted kicks up next
the unique Souls designed to pump up one
unique soul
you don't have to walk a mile in someone
else's shoes to know one size doesn't
fit all
a Calgary woman who lives with cerebral
palsy knows that all too well so when
she reached out to a Canadian company
known for its fashionable Footwear she
found herself in her own Cinderella
story yield croteau reports it's the
kind of thing that really makes a
statement fashionable Footwear and that
inclination to have the perfect pair is
universal as a self-esteem thing to wear
to wear something like this is a huge
boost shoes aren't one size fits all and
when you're drawn to a certain style
there should be no limits but for Darby
Lee Young there are my gate I dragged my
toes so for me to wear shoes they last
anywhere between a week to a month to
even a day she lives with cerebral palsy
and approached Canadian shoe designer
John Fluevog the company is known for
making its mark in a real edgy way staff
wanted to walk a mile in someone else's
shoes and it was more than just a
metaphor
Alison flew by actually wrote me back
and said hey we love your story thanks
so much but how would we make you a
parents that kind of wait what and then
she said Owen by the way we're gonna
call them the Derby and sell them
throughout all our stores I'm like oh my
god for the past two years designers
collaborated with her to create a shoe
with a sturdy rubber sole it's removable
and easier to repair the two styles hit
the stores in their 2020 Spring
Collection unreal unreal it's in my
wildest dreams never sorry for me it's
it showed that somebody actually listens
and understands that people with
disabilities have great differences when
it comes to shoes especially and people
have actually commented across the world
now we know who the Derby is behind the
derbies at flu bug we always have kind
of done unique souls for unique Souls
and so our design team kind of went back
and forth with her well
this is something that kind of would
work really well and fit what you're
asking so let's go back and forth in
terms of colors you know different
little bits and elements that will make
this a little bit more uniquely you and
now in Derby slips on her trademark shoe
she admits there's a little something
extra in the way she walks my mother
always taught me that if people are
gonna stare you might as well look good
doing it
Jill croteau Global News what a lovely
story that is global national for this
Saturday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is lake louise alberta we would
love to see your corner of this country
so email your pictures to viewers at
global national calm thank you for
watching and i'll see you back here
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]